(cheerful music)
- [Narrator] This is
just a typical morning.
I'm eating some cereal
with lactose-free milk
as I watched some videos on the internet
using closed captioning,
while looking up directions
to my MRI appointment.
Okay, maybe not really typical
but just about everything here,
the milk, the TV, the
graphics cards, the internet,
the closed captioning,
the GPS, the MRI machine
were made possible because
of government investments.
- It's probably the case that
every technology used today,
at some point there was like
government funding involved.
- [Narrator] And the latest technology
that the US government
is getting involved in
is manufacturing microchips.
- Folks, we need to make
these chips here in America.
- It's law.
- President Biden just
signed a bill into law today
boosting domestic
semiconductor production.
- There are some big companies
that are set to benefit.
- If it's a good idea to
make the semiconductors here,
why do we need the government to help us?
- [Narrator] Here's why the US government
is giving private companies
billions of dollars
and why many economists
are calling the Chips Act
a return to industrial policy.
- Industrial policy is
actually quite a simple term.
It's a set of policies that
try to affect the outcome
of some particular industry or industries.
- [Narrator] Industrial policy
can be done through things like tariffs
that make US made products
cheaper than foreign ones,
or through tax incentives
like getting money back
if you put solar panels on your house,
or what has been less
popular in recent years,
direct investments.
Let's go back, way back
to Alexander Hamilton.
In 1790, Hamilton proposed
tariffs on imported goods
in order to encourage
his fellow countrymen
to buy more American products.
- [Speaker] This is the
immense plant which gave birth
to the atomic bomb and brought
the world to a new crossroad.
- [Narrator] Fast forward
to the 20th Century,
to prevent the spread of
radioactive contaminants
used during the Manhattan Project,
the US government funded the
development of the HEPA filter
which is used in many
air purifiers sold today.
World War II also required
enormous investment
in radio technology, ship
building and jet engines.
- The defense department was largely
the main buyer of many
of these technologies.
The commercial market was quite small,
the defense market was quite big.
And so they could really drive
a lot of the movement in industry.
- [Narrator] In the 1960s,
the US government spent more money
on research and development
than all other governments,
all foreign private companies
and all US private companies combined.
Why?
The Cold War and the Space Race?
- What did the space program give us?
It gave us Tang
- [Speaker] From Gemini to
the Shuttle to Earth families,
- [Both] Bye, mom.
- [Speaker] Great mornings
have taken off with Tang.
- Yeah, it gave us Tang,
but it also gave a gazillion other things.
It wasn't talked about
as industrial policy.
It was talked about as space policy
or defense policy or health policy,
but it was a defacto industrial policy.
- [Speaker] And liftoff.
- [Narrator] A defacto industrial policy
with many unforeseen benefits.
This robotic prosthetic leg
is powered by small, powerful motors,
originally designed for a robotic arm
on the International Space Station.
Like many of these technologies,
semiconductors originated
from research and development programs
funded by the US taxpayer.
- The birth of semiconductors
in the United States
had a lot to do with the fact
that the Department of Defense
and the space program were the first
big early customers for semiconductors.
- [Narrator] Since 2006,
China has prioritized
catching up to the west technologically.
But doing that requires semiconductors.
- China has ramped up
its investment in Chips.
- [Narrator] Senator Mark
Warner, who is the chairman
of the Senate Select
Committee on Intelligence
has long been warning
about the growing threat posed by China.
- China has been able to
throw literally, you know,
two, three, four times as much
money at trying to build up
their semiconductor chip
capacity as the United States.
- [Narrator] This is where
the Chips Act comes in.
The legislation offers $53
billion in direct investment
plus a separate tax incentive program
to reinvigorate the US chip industry.
- So, what the Chips bill did was say,
we're gonna take 52 billion,
but we're going to take
about 40 billion of that
and try to get the semiconductor factories
that are called Fabs,
get the Fabs to locate here in America
- [Narrator] Today, the US still dominates
the most lucrative links in
the semiconductor supply chain
including the design of chips.
But the fabrication of chips
has increasingly moved to
China, South Korea, and Taiwan.
- Over the last 20 years,
a lot of that industry
has migrated to East Asia
where land and labor are cheaper
and there are a lot of subsidies available
- [Narrator] Because of this,
the US share of global chip making
has shrunk from 37% in
1990 to 12% in 2020.
China went from zero to
about 15% in the same time.
- If we don't do this, I don't
think there'll be another
chip manufacturing
facility built in America.
- Senator Warner sees this
as a national security issue.
- Over the last
particularly 15 or 20 years,
what we've seen is that national security
is no longer who has the
most military hardware
but also who controls
what technology domains.
- [Narrator] The US now buys more than 90%
of its advanced chips from Taiwan,
an island China sees as its territory.
Any conflict in Taiwan
could dramatically disrupt
global chip supplies.
- We all saw what happened
during the pandemic
when chip factories shut down overseas.
We can never let that happen again.
- We have never before been
in this kind of a Cold War type conflict
with a power that was also
a worthy economic peer.
And I think it is awakened,
in the United States,
an awareness that we cannot simply allow
the private market to
allow vital technologies
and capabilities to entirely
migrate to a country
that we are in an
adversarial situation with.
- So our competitors are pouring
tens of billion dollars into
boosting their own supply
of these essential semiconductors,
and the United States needs
to keep up and to compete.
The vast majority of our colleagues
agree that this was an
important and critical task.
- [Narrator] When was passed,
the Chips Act received
rare bipartisan support.
The yays are 64, the nays are 33.
- There is broad bipartisan agreement
that China is the challenge of our time,
and that in these areas of technology
we can't allow America to fall behind.
- [Narrator] Critics of industrial policy
accuse it of picking winners
rather than letting the
free market determine
which companies succeed.
Some of the most famous
industrial policy failures
include investment targeted
at a single company.
At former President Donald Trump's urging,
in 2017, Taiwan's Foxconn
Technology Group promised to build
a flat panel display factory in Wisconsin.
- This is a great day for American workers
and for everyone who believes
in the concept and the
label, Made in the USA.
- But five years later, and
that factory remains unbuilt.
Critics of industrial policy
also point to Solyndra
- When it's completed in a few months,
Solyndra expects to hire 1,000 workers
to manufacture solar panels
and sell them across America
and around the world.
(audience applauding)
- [Narrator] But in 2011,
the solar manufacturer went bankrupt
after it defaulted on $535
million in federal loans.
But proponents of the Chips Act say,
it's not about picking specific firms
like Intel or Taiwan Semiconductor
- Good industrial policy
funds a variety of firms,
big, small, even foreign,
long as they're doing the work in the US
and they're not our adversaries.
- [Narrator] The ability
to apply for this money
is drawing major investment
from these firms right now.
Both Intel and TSMC are spending billions
to build new Fabs in the US.
- I think one thing we're gonna learn
is that industrial policy is expensive
and we have large government deficits.
And so, I think one of the
things that will put the breaks
on the Rush to industrial
policy is the fact that
you'll have to persuade, you know,
Congress to vote for this money
and that's not easy to do.
The Republican senators, for example,
who gave their support to the Chips Act,
they did so because they saw this
as a narrow exception to
their general mistrust
of the government being
able to spend money
better than the free market.
And I think that there will not be
many other industries that meet that test.
(cheerful music)